[Applaus]
[Musik]
welche bilder gehen die als erstes durch
den kopf wenn du die wörter geheimagent
und spion wirst wahrscheinlich sind es
filmszenen aus james bond wilde
verfolgungsjagd ein klarer fall und
heiße affären mit dem schärfsten girls
an allerlei exotischen würde was dir
aber trotz dieser medial implantierten
bilder auch klar sein dürfte ist das der
berufsalltag realer spione damit rein
gar nichts zu tun hat aber das alles
macht ja durchaus sehen weil ich ein
normaler mensch würde sich in einen film
reinsetzen in dem sean connery 120
minuten lagen telefongespräche abhört
oder meta daten auswertet aber genau
darauf läuft es im grunde hinaus wenn
von spionage die rede ist
seit den zeiten des alten roms bis zum
heutigen tag hat nachrichtendienste im
grunde vor allem eine aufgabe
herauszufinden wer was zudem gesagt hat
tja julius cäsar verfügte zwar nicht
über high tech computer oder satelliten
aber er konnte dem tod mehrmals entgehen
weil ihm ein leistungsfähiges netz von
informanten zur verfügung stand es wird
sogar behauptet dass er möglicherweise
selbst von jeder verschwörung wusste die
ihn schließlich sein leben kostete ein
weiteres beispiel die von orbis de und
konsorten losgetreten französische
revolution werde höchstwahrscheinlich
auch ohne ein netz aus der hand geben
nicht möglich gewesen zumindest nicht
auf die art und weise wie sie
stattgefunden hat
die revolutionsregierung verfügte im
ganzen land über geheimdienst komitees
diese waren für die identifizierung
überwachung und verhaftung alle adligen
ausländer und aus den ausland
zurückkehren den franzosen zuständig
geben für alle potenziellen gegner der
revolution damit du dir eine vorstellung
vom ausmaß dieses überwachungsapparat
machen kannst einige historiker schätzen
die zahl der von diesen riesigen
spionagenetzwerk überwachten personen
auf fast eine halbe million so und nun
lasst uns aus dem 18 jahrhundert direkt
ins jahr 2013 springen in jedem jahr
rüttelte der whistleblower etwas snowden
allmächtigen in washington gehörig auf
über journalisten der washington post
und das guardian ließ der ehemalige
cia-mitarbeiter als streng geheim
eingestufte dokumente durchsickern
darin werden verschiedene geheimdienste
kammer beschrieben durch welche
metadaten von us bürgern in großem
umfang gesammelt werden aber um welche
programme genau handelt er sich was
genau macht die nsa wirklich welche
rolle spielt sie bei nine eleven in
bezug auf privatsphäre fasse ich genau
das interessiert anhören und gut zu denn
in diesem video werden wir alle diese
fragen beantworten
der geheimdienst
am 20 mai 1949 gründete der damalige
us-verteidigungsminister lose johnson
die art vorschuss security agency kurz
fsme also die sicherheitsbehörde der
amerikanischen streitkräfte
jetzt weg war es die gesamte
elektronische kommunikation und die
nachrichtendienstliche erkenntnisse der
verschiedenen behörden der streitkräfte
zu koordinieren zb dessert for service
und der marine security group die afa
wurde zu einem grandiosen flop denn die
rivalitäten zwischen den verschiedenen
behörden waren so groß dass sie letzten
endes so gut wie keine relevanten
informationen mit dieser zentralen
organisation teilen wollten
genau aus diesem grund und weil die fsa
am ende völlig unfähig war auch die
erfordernisse des neuen kalten krieges
reagiert und schloss passt weltruhm an
im juni 1952 etwas völlig neues auf den
weg zu bringen
und da die gründung eines neuen
geheimdiensten aus er kann dies durch
ein vertrauliches memo genauer gesagt
als klitzekleine anmerkung dass am ende
siegten seite des dokuments eine
klitzekleine anmerkung welche die
geschichte der spionage in nordamerika
für immer verändern sollte
kannst du dir vorstellen wie truman
damals dieses dokument seiner sekretärin
diktiert hat sechs saiten blablabla dann
plötzlich von allein so so wird es
einzig noch so freundlich im fügen sie
am ende noch einen kleinen punkt ein
dass wir ein mega geheimnis schaffen
werden aber machen sie da jetzt kein
großes aufsehen raus denn das beste wäre
wenn das niemand wirklich mit kriegen
würde nicht einmal der kongress aber
eigentlich vor allem nicht der kongress
wie auch immer auf diese weise wurde die
nsa geboren und so wurde erst mehr als
20 jahre später öffentlich bekannt dass
es diese agentur überhaupt gibt dann
nämlich also überhaupt nicht mehr gegen
sie totzuschweigen im rahmen von
untersuchungen die 1975 hat über den
möglichen missbrauch der us-geheimdienst
durchgeführt wurden damals enthüllte ein
sonderausschuss des us-senats namens
search committee dass es eine zuvor
unbekannte organisation gibt die jedes
jahr von der regierung mit einem multi
millionen dollar
die ausgestattet wird und niemand hatte
die von ihr gehört selbst die senatoren
schenken damals den ausmaß welche die
nsa erreicht hatte keinen glauben
im gegensatz zur wii durch den kongress
die parlamente also der legislative ins
leben gerufen wurde war die nsa direkt
von der exekutive also von der us
regierung ins leben gerufen worden und
über die jahrzehnte hat das weiße haus
alles um die organisation völlig
unbemerkt vor sich hin werkeln und immer
weiter und weiter wachsen zu lassen im
kongress gründen sie es einfach nicht
glauben
sie hatten gerade herausgefunden dass
die nsa eine praktisch unbegrenzte
organisation nicht nur eine größere
behörde war als die cia selbst nein die
nsa war mittlerweile größer als alle
übrigen us geheimdienste zusammen
genommen damit du dir eine vorstellung
von ihrer größer machen kannst im jahr
1978 hat er die nsa trotz der kürzungen
durch das ende des vietnamkriegs immer
über 68.000 mitarbeiter das ist mehr als
die hälfte aller heutigen mitarbeiter
von apple dem weltweit wertvollsten
unternehmen ja und das alles unter
absoluter geheimhaltung trotz ihrer
grösse und macht ist nie ein gesetz
erlassen worden dass der nsa irgendeine
tätigkeit untersagt es gibt auch kein
gesetz welches die gründung oder den
zulässigen umfang ihrer
verantwortlichkeiten regelt die einzigen
gesetze zur nsa seien diejenigen welche
es verbieten informationen über die nsa
herauszugeben
frank schorge ehemalige vorsitzende des
geheimdienst ausschusses des us-senats
und wenn dir das schon für einen
demokratischen staat recht komisch
vorkommt dann fertig ist fest denn die
geschichte endet hier noch lange nicht
[Applaus]
us-senat entdeckte damals auch dass die
nsa die telefone schon fast 1700
us-bürgern abhört bereits 1969 legte die
regierung nächsten eine spezielle liste
mit personen auf die es zu beobachten
gilt diese sollte als operation minarett
bekannt werden und diese war an und für
sich schon hochgradig skandalös denn es
dient um solch prominente
persönlichkeiten wie martin luther tel
denn von da und mohamed ali sie alle
standen auf dieser merkwürdigen
schwarzen liste der nsa tatsächlich war
nächsten derart paranoid dass er sogar
seine eigenen leute ausbilden ließ so
stand beispielsweise der bekannte
republikanische senator aus tennessee
powered by creation mehrheitsführer im
senat wurde und später stabschef von das
pentagon war ebenfalls auf der
verdächtigenliste im jahr 1978
verabschiedete der us-kongress dann aber
den sogenannten apps
dieser den foreign intelligence
surveillance act wahrscheinlich als
folge der enthüllungen rund um die
hochgradig umstritten arbeitsweise der
nsa
lisa sollte den expansionsdrang der nsa
alles und jeden nach lust und laune
abzuhören erst mal bremsen
mit der verabschiedung dieses gesetzes
konnte die nsa nur noch kommunikationen
die im ausland stattfinden belauschen
außerdem wurde die überwachung von
us-bürgern ausdrücklich untersagt außer
es bestand der verdacht sie würden für
ein anderes land spionieren um us-bürger
abzuhören musste die nsa nun einen
gerichtsbeschluss einholen so wie zum
beispiel die polizei auch so weit so gut
dann aber kam es zu jenem ereignis das
die kleinsten dieses geheimdienstes
völlig verändert würde
der tag der alles veränderte
ein bestimmtes datum ist der
entscheidende wendepunkt in der
geschichte nsa und du kannst es dir
sicher denken welches dieses ist der
elfter september 2001 fast zwei
jahrzehnte nach diesem schicksalhaften
tag können wir mit ziemlicher sicherheit
sagen dass nine eleven die
folgenreichste terroristische operation
in der geschichte der menschheit war an
jedem tag endete das leben 3000
unschuldiger menschen sowie etwa mörder
19 wahnsinniger dschihadisten geben so
endete die existenz eines ikonischen
gebäude paris der zwillingstürme des
world trade center sowie von
passagierflugzeugen
aber nicht nur das es gab viele dinge
die zwar nicht zerstört aber für immer
verändert und beschädigt wurden tausende
von verwundeten und traumatisierten das
pentagon gebäude und ein land das nie
wieder dasselbe sein würde der elfter
september hat die politische agenda der
bush regierung definiert und wir
sprechen nicht nur über die kriege in
afghanistan und im irak
der kongress gab dem damaligen
präsidenten bush praktisch einen
blankoscheck um die streitkräfte in
jeder weise einzusetzen die er für
notwendig erachtete um jeden der an den
angriffen beteiligt wasser verfolgen und
zu bestrafen
[Musik]
das waren höchst als einen monat nach
dem 11 september verabschiedete der
kongress den patriot act ein gesetz das
die sicherheitsbehörden ermächtigte den
terrorismus mit den gleichen mitteln zu
bekämpfen die sie auch zur bekämpfung
des organisierten verbrechens und des
drogenhandels anwenden konnten band
estate konnten agenten beispielsweise
zugang zu anrufen vorgeschichte
reiseplänen und anderen informationen
eines terrorverdächtigen alten die
andere bereiten bereits gesammelt hatten
aber das war noch lange nicht alles denn
wenn ein level für jemanden ein schlag
ins gesicht darstellt dann sind dies
definitiv die geheimdienste der usa und
die antwort darauf war mehr viel mehr
aufklärung und spionage
[Musik]
im jahr 2002 unterzeichnete präsident
bush ein geheimnis sehen welcher ist der
nse erlaubte anrufe e-mails und tausende
von us-bürgern und in den usa ansässigen
personen zu überwachen
ohne einen gerichtsbeschluss einholen zu
müssen dies war die geburtsstunde des
stella wind programms doch das
sahnehäubchen kam 2005 mit der ernennung
eines neuen direktors ein mann der eine
neue äre einer geschichte der nsa und
damit auch in der geschichte der
spionage einläutete
ein cowboy in washington
am ersten august 2005 wurde alexander so
16 direktor der lwl und er sollte die
nsa insgesamt neun jahre lang führen
dass es durchaus ungewöhnlich denn kein
anderer zuvor war jemals so lange
direktor der nsa und kein anderer
direktor des so viel macht in seinen
händen wie alexander sein ehrgeiz war
grenzen und beispiellos alexander neigte
dazu ein bisschen wie ein cowboy zu sein
machen wir uns keine sorgen um das
gesetz lasst uns einfach herausfinden
wie wir die arbeit erledigen können sagt
ein ehemaliger geheimdienstmitarbeiter
er sagte einmal dass viele dinge nicht
eindeutig legal sind aber das mache sie
jedoch nicht illegal so ein ehemaliger
offizier des militärgeheimdienstes der
unter alexander enns kommen diente
anscheinend alexander der perfekte mann
für den job zu sein er war ein hoch
dekorierter geheimdienstoffizier ein
absolvent vorne west point der sich auch
physik und technologie spezialisiert
hatte
zum beispiel leistete er während des
irak-kriegs pionierarbeit bei der
überwachung der gesamten kommunikation
anrufe e-mails und nachrichten die aus
dem irak kam und das alles in echtzeit
sein vorgänger der ehemalige
generaldirektor michael hayden konnte
alexanders anblick jedoch nicht ertragen
aber alexander hatte nicht nur einen
sondern zwei asse im ärmel um an die
spitze zu gelangen
erstens wusste er das handy damaligen
verteidigungsminister donald rumsfeld
haste und so machte er rumsfeld zu
seinen ersten ziehen
und zweitens fühlte er sich irgendwie
kreis wie ein fisch im wasser
sagen wir einfach er wusste wie man
menschen für sich gewinnen konnte die
man braucht um alle seine ziele zu
erreichen
ein richtiges politiker in den ring
kongress abgeordnete senatoren berater
des weißen hauses jay alexander knüpfte
mit ihnen allen ein ähnliches netzwerk
von abhängigkeiten der
vier-sterne-general leitete damals ein
geheimnis kommando in virginia in der
nähe von washington nun damit du dir
eine vorstellung davon waren kannst
welche art von menschen extender ist
muss dir vorstellen dass er in seinem
quartier eine nachbildung des commando
decks des raumschiffs enterprise nachbau
liest und wenn du dich fragst warum in
aller welt sollte er das tun nur zum ein
und kontrollierte er von seinem star
trek gefechtsstand voller bildschirme
und computer ein sogenanntes information
domain center aber das war nicht alles
denn immer wenn er ein politiker zur
besichtigung der anlage einlud dies als
ein gast auf dem vermeintlichen sessel
des kapitäns der enterprise setzen und
die politiker liebten es sie waren wie
verzaubert und traten ihn aus der hand
ja es ist kaum zu glauben aber mit der
art platter manipulation gelangt ist ein
exzellenter irgendwie alle auf seine
seite zu ziehen und die auf diese weise
würde auch zu direktor der wichtigen nsa
aber lassen wir uns nicht von diesen
anekdoten ablenken
tatsache ist dass während alexander
seiner amtszeit eines seiner hauptziele
darin bestand die agentur technologisch
so erneuert und einer jener charaktere
welche die von alexander forcierten
veränderungen in der nsa am besten
repräsentiert ist ausgerechnet adwords
snowden
alexander füllte den geheimdienst mit
frischem jungen personal über nacht
liefen ins zentrale über als 20 jährige
grüßte müll herum und zwar mit
zugriffsberechtigung welche selbst die
ranghöchsten agenten nie erreicht hatten
das digitale zeitalter war angebrochen
ich war jahrzehnte jünger als die hälfte
und ging an ihnen vorbei in einem
tresorraum zu dem sie keinen zugang
hatten und nie haben würden in oslo die
mit seinen frisch angestellten in seiner
neu gestalteten nsa ging alexander so
dann sofort das über neue innovative
spionage programme aufzulegen eines der
umstrittensten davon war das pressen
programm
damit begann die nsa informationen aus
dem internet und von
technologieunternehmen zu speichern
emails video-chats social media
nachrichten alles war eine reichweite
der analysten der behörde
nach hinweisen auf neue terroristische
bedrohungen zu suchen tatsächlich wurde
von dieser behörde so viele
informationen gespeichert dass die nsa
auf ihren 101 hektar am stützpunkt fort
keine lagerkapazitäten mehr zur
verfügung stand sie mussten ihre
festplatte erweitern indem sie mitten in
der wüste von utah einen ganz neuen
gigantischen stützpunkt errichteten der
mehr als 2 milliarden dollar
und was schätzt du wie viele personen
von der nsa im rahmen dieses programms
überwacht wurden
wie viele terror verdächtige gab es nun
es handelte sich um dutzende millionen
us bürger genau us bürger also genau
jene welche die nsa eigentlich einen
richterlichen beschluss bräuchte also
dutzende von millionen solcher
beschlüsse und hatte sie diese oder wie
hat die nsa die überwachung so viele
menschen rechtlich die rechtfertigt nun
wie man so schön sagt wo ein gesetz ist
da ist auch ein schlupfloch chris
englisch der stellvertretende direktor
der behörde erklärte im kongress wenn
ein potentieller terrorist unter
beobachtung stehe würden mitteilungen
von allen personen die mit ihm über drei
ecken in verbindung stehen untersucht
aber was genau bedeutet über drei ecken
mit jemanden in verbindung stehen nun
eine kürzlich von der universität
mailand durchgeführte social media
studie
derzeit alle über im schnitt 4,7 ecken
mit jedem anderen menschen verbunden
sind ja und da kommt schon einiges
zusammen wenn man wie die nsa alle über
drei ecken vertonung einbezieht da
fehlen ja nur noch 1,7 ecken bis zur
kompletten abdeckung der menschheit
eigentlich einsetzt werden praktisch
hatten sie dadurch freie hand jeden
abzuhören den sie wollten
alexander hatte all diese diagramme die
zeigten wie dieser typ mit diesem typ
und mit jenem typ verbunden war so ein
ehemaliger nsa bernd a einige meiner
kollegen und ich waren skeptisch später
hatten wir gelegenheit die informationen
zu überprüfen
es stellte sich heraus dass die einzige
gemeinsame verbindung dieser menschen
eine pizzeria war
sie hatten einfach alle im selben
restaurant ihre pizza bestellt ein
pensionierter militäroffizier der mit
alexander arbeitete
die abhör orgie nsa gerieten somit total
außer kontrolle durchgesickerten
dokumente zeigen dass allein in spanien
und frankreich mehr als zehn millionen
telefongespräche abgefangen wurden
tatsächlich lässt du dich vielleicht
noch an jenen oberbayerischen moment der
regierung obama barack obama genehmigte
vor drei jahren das abhören des telefons
von angela merkel
präsident barack obama wurde über die
überwachung der deutschen
bundeskanzlerin im jahr 2010 informiert
und erlaubte deren fortsetzung mehr das
telefon e-mails des damaligen
mexikanischen präsidenten felipe
calderón und 35 weitere staatschefs das
ausmaß der überwachung war so groß dass
adwords snowden zu erkennen begann das
sms angestellte gab die vollkommen
ungestraft jeden ausspionieren auf der
sie gerade lust hatten zb ihrer ex
partner und die erneut partner und nach
den zig milliarden dollar für diese
programme ausgegeben worden waren
kündigte die nsa selbst anfang 2009 10
an das programm auszusetzen bis dahin
hat er es telekommunikationsfirmen
verpflichtet der nsa vollen zugang zu
ihren netzen zu gewähren nach angaben
der nsa selbst waren die vorteile im
vergleich zu den kosten und den
eingesetzten ressourcen recht gering es
scheint dass die auswertung einer so
großen datenmenge in der praxis nicht
einfacher
wahrscheinlich gelangten die geniale
mittler nsa zum schluss dass die eigenen
leute das programm zu jenem zeitpunkt
erst im osten ihren angela merkel
nutzten als zur bekämpfung von
terroristen aber trotz aller offiziellen
verlautbarungen über die einstellung des
programms können wir jemals sicher sein
dass es wirklich abgeschaltet wurde oder
nicht logischer weise einfach durch ein
neues moderneres und noch perfides
ersetzt offiziell wurde vereinbart dass
nun doch wieder die privatsphäre von
millionen und abermillionen von menschen
auf der ganzen welt respektiert werden
soll obwohl zuvor aber milliarden von
dollar dafür investiert wurden um jeden
wortfetzen egal ob ins telefon
gesprochen oder internet getippt
mitzuschneiden auszuwerten
in einer riesigen datenbank gut
indexiert zu aktivieren so dass
jederzeit über eine komfortable
suchfunktion wieder alles über jeden
herausgekramt werden kann
denn man kann ja nicht wissen wozu ist
gut sein könnte und wenn sie nicht
gestorben sind dann haben sie diese
datenbank noch heute
wie auch immer freunde das war die
geschichte eines der geheimnisvollsten
geheimnisse der welt ein geheimdienst
von dessen heutigen aktivitäten wird
keine ahnung haben und den wir lediglich
wissen dass er noch vor kurzem in der
lage war die privatsphäre von millionen
und abermillionen unschuldiger bürger
skrupellos zu verletzten unter ihnen
geschäftsleute politiker und
journalisten und die sollte uns
veranlassen uns einige fragen zu stellen
ist nur es für angemessen dass eine
regierungsbehörde über ein solches maß
an befugnissen verfügt ohne durch eine
vom gesetzgeber berufen kontrollinstanz
bist du bereit eine gesamte privatsphäre
zu opfern um die angebliche nationale
sicherheit zu stärken welchen
kontrollmechanismen sollte deiner
meinung nach eine solche behörde
unterworfen sein
schreib uns deine meinung bitte in den
kommentaren zu diesem video
wir hoffen dass wir dieses video etwas
gebracht hat falls ja gib uns bitte auch
einen daumen hoch und unterstützer uns
indem du es mit deinen freunden heißt
vergisst auch nicht dass wir jede woche
neue videos mit klaren also das ist
eines unserer updates abonniere unseren
kanal und blick auch auf das minus
hingegen um rechtzeitig benachrichtigt
zu werden muss gut und ist zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]